[Musique]
je suis né
ici je suis de Paris
Paris
cou J
Sur Je
conis jeis pas et a Je pas pour les mais
aais
dans l'équilibre pas
mauvais équilibre
mauvais solde mauvais solde de Paris
aussi le solde a mal tourné Le solde de Paris a mal tourné
J'ai aussi eu un spectacle et il m'est parti
mais du nouveau c'est tout ce que je
J'ai vu plus que copié Ginger ou
pourquoi toujours
amica c'est bien fini le paraplu c'était
Joli mais je veux faire quelque chose
Moi devrai travailler mais pourquoi pas
solde pas mauvais Paris solde pas
mauvais solde mauvais solde de Paris
aussi le solde a mal tourné Le solde de Paris a mal tourné
aussi lesa Plus de notre
ère
la meille c'est Plus la
solde pas mauvais Paris solde pas
mauvais solde mauvais solde de Paris
aussi le solde a mal tourné Le solde de Paris a mal tourné
aussi l'équilibre
un mauvais équilibre s'est produit
mauvais équilibre pas mauvais cantonnière Paris
Aï
tu es
[Musique]
fade